are you guys going to get married before
bobby and i
probably yeah
unless unless you're going to propose at
the house no we don't do proposals it's
going to be one of those shotgun i might
as well you think bobby's not going to
propose no where i feel like we've had
this talk before and this is what bobby
says he's like babe i just don't know
how to do it
he goes do i call abby
and if i ask you yeah and you say no
i would never say i know but if you said
no to me and i asked you
that would that would scar me for all of
life
that's worse than the dog posters
i know but i'm a nightmare you better
say yes i'm a knight i've given you so
much nightmare
dreamt of a nightmare my whole life i
never wanted easy yeah what kind of guys
do you like i
i didn't think i could get
the type of
the inspiration
the two worlds
i like them fat and wild
i've always dreamt of a man i said i
need i need a fat and wild man and
that's honestly a good album when i do
what no when i do what's special
that's the title
fat and wild
yeah i love that yeah yeah i love it and
that was always my first instinct when i
first moved to america
my first boyfriend
josh he wrote a bmx he was fat and wild
and then as my hair grew out and i took
my braces out all of a sudden i shifted
and i got cuter boys but then i had to
go back home yeah where the fat and
wilds were yeah yeah
it really is an interesting um
person to be
being fat and wild
you know
because you
you can surprise people
like if they don't know who i am right
and i walk into
a nightclub
they're going to see some [ __ ]
like
dancing they've never seen before
me disappear reappear
um if especially when i'm using doing
drugs oh be careful i'd blow everyone
fat wild crazy yeah
you know what i mean yeah eat [ __ ]
too oh one [ __ ] just one but blow a lie
i blow everyone blow everyone i wonder
who it is here's the thing that i got
mad at the other day speaking of poetry
it's kind of spoken word uh i was
watching online
r shafir
did you know his this is not happening
he has it his own comedy central show
where he tells stories i've done it
before yeah that was a good one but i
saw one where he did it before i've ever
done it
bobby lee and i go get a prostitute
[Laughter]
now
he never called me
and said hey can i tell this story about
us getting a prostitute i thought you
did it with him no he just not that
story okay bobby but we've talked about
i understand it's principle baby
because if you would have called me you
said hey can i tell the story about i'd
be like yeah all right you know what i
mean permission but just the thought
that he just you know i mean did this
crazy story about it's funny story yeah
you know i mean but it's like it makes
me seem
disgusting you are disgusting
there's no other better word to describe
you than disgusting you are that
i am what i totally get white
what do you mean
you're you're a disgusting
creature
whoa
you are
as am i that's why this works together
that's why
exists
but disgusting in what way
i mean
i don't think that you getting a
prostitute is disgusting i just think
that
and what i mean disgusting not in a
negative way it's more like
you do [ __ ]
that the average person wouldn't
get into
for example give me examples
you know 69 with we know family members
okay stop
stop okay
yes
i did 69 with a family member
and it happened to him be a man
a boy but
that was a i was a kid yeah and and is
it because i talk about it that i'm
disgusting or because i actually did
that
i mean gosh i don't you because a lot of
kids have done weird things that they
would never talk about yeah like i don't
george i don't know what he's done yeah
but i know he's done some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
in his personal life yes you have yeah
you did jordan yeah you did george but
overall you are just disgusting like
even with hygiene though let's keep it
real okay all right that's this is about
being real yeah and this is about me on
honestly
looking myself in the mirror and going
okay let's let's find out who i really
am all right so tell me
all you need to do is take this camera
and then see your side of the bed
what's on your side of the bed sunflower
seeds i love them three-year-old banana
peels delicious
smoothies he has just let dry out
fermenting like fermenting
i mean just fish guts like
fish that's wrong you did that as a joke
and that's wrong
there's there's never been fish that's
on the side of my bed
all right oh oh go inside this car
actually it straight up smells like
horse maneuver and i can't figure out
why because i ride horses i i take i
took his car to get washed i'd interior
an exterior and right after that it
still smells like
[ __ ] animal manure and i can't figure
out why
and it's because it's just years and
years and years of like fermenting
whatever in there maybe you're right i
don't know i don't know how to change
that about myself
hygiene wise yeah just i'm just a dirty
dirty person
and i've always have been and it's like
i've
i've gotten by this far for being you
know you know what you don't have though
body odor thank you i was gonna say and
that's a fact
you know what's so random um so the guy
that we train with your friend
the was elliot elliott jones it turns
out we know the same thing i've been
doing muay thai but he convinced me to
do muay thai with him all right you know
whatever you gotta do it but you wanna
hear the funniest [ __ ] [ __ ] so the
way elliott speaks of kalila's
relationship with each other it's like
the the coolest friendliest thing ever
right they're like yeah we're still
really close and then we call her up she
goes well [ __ ] that guy
he said that that we're all really close
yeah that guy just ghosted on our
friendship after i was friends with him
for eight years because he got a new
girlfriend that's the truth
and actually that same that same day
when you guys um called me i texted him
i was like hey dude are we still friends
where are you and he never texted me
back interesting well your text was kind
of aggressive my text was a little bit
no i put a happy face are we still
friends
but look at the tone in your voice right
now
don't ever point
don't ever point your finger at me like
that again
like this
don't ever do that again dude all right
that's my [ __ ] girlfriend come to my
house
no i'm just saying when people go that's
all you do is mad tv [ __ ] you oh that's
what okay that makes sense okay i was
like why is he telling us i know he's
people say that people are not saying
that are they no yeah i walked into uh
where was i i was at the airport at
brookstone yeah and the mexican dude are
you at a brookstone this is why i was
waiting you know what he does he buys an
excess massage those massagers that he
puts on his penis
those are for clitorises
no no no no no no there's like seven
17
i'll i'll get them they're all under the
bed it's private private he never uses
it on me only himself
he vibrates the tip of his dick when he
jerks off he goes
so it touches the little vibrating thing
bob explained yourself
i was there um at brookstone
looking at stuff so anyway fun dip um
well usually how candy works is you like
if you get high too right unless you
want because i'm like yeah i do this is
going to be the lowest view podcast
so anyway you open this up like this
right you have this to anyone if you
[ __ ] it up
and then you open this part
you up with the powder right and then
you can't just do this right it's gotta
be wet you can't just stick this in here
like this dude oh you gotta lick it yeah
you know when you the dick you know when
the dick goes in the [ __ ] the dick has
to be you know that some women spit on
it
you spin that spit on the dick
oh my god oh jesus
you've definitely been molested dude
all right i can't even look at you
right yeah
i can't i can't do it hey you guys are
close come on you guys are good you guys
are good friends and there's just like
so many levels of therapy
you stick it right in the [ __ ] right
right and you [ __ ] drown it in there
right
right and it comes out dry it comes out
dry like this right
you stuck your own dick again right
and then you're done right you calm
right come right
you know what
what
i was trying to say it was unacceptable
but it's hard when you're laughing not
also you know why
do you know why it's not unacceptable
right it's because it's candy and it
happened to you and it happened to me
right done that's right
done
boom
oh let's do it again you stick it in oh
my god
no let me switch you stick it in right
right you come right right like this
right
she's still
she's awake
and she's but then what you do is you
take a hammer yes but let me tell you
if kit harington
called me and said bobby
let's let's [ __ ] right i would go to
[ __ ] that's how he sounds by the way
yeah it's dead-on all right
i would go to [ __ ] north face get a
woolly jacket a woolly jacket go to
ireland wherever the [ __ ] he lives
and i would i would bite the inner his
inner thigh gently as a mark as a mark
so then he said that when she [ __ ] him
she'll know i was there she was like
[ __ ] bobby got some first yeah if you
see like [ __ ] fang marks on his inner
thigh that's papa i don't mind sloppy
seconds from you i don't even mind
sloppy 20th like i'll take anything from
him
i'll take anything he's not gonna [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
if he wanted and that's a guarantee
right now kit arrington right now uh-oh
you can have this [ __ ] right here for
free
right no i don't have a chance with him
all i'm saying is i'll get all the
[ __ ] oils together i'll jerk off
whatever you need bro but here we go
dude
no dinner nothing all right because i'm
gonna tell you something right now
you're not going to want that did you um
do you always eat like korean barbecue
is that like your main panic yeah that's
like your main thing like crane barbecue
no i i eat [ __ ] you man i eat what the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you man you know what i eat man
i'll tell you my places i eat you know
you know this in two weeks this is where
i'll go
uh connie and ted's
seafood okay okay
i'll go to um
what's that cat place
cat place hungry cat hungry cat seafood
seafood okay i was like
i don't know what the wink means
life okay to you my friend all right
okay
hungry cat i go to [ __ ] kanye ted's
i'll go to um
i'll go to um
jiu jitsu what's that place last night i
went to jiu jitsu
because they closed at two in the
morning
and sometimes i'll go to the annex and
sometimes they'll go across the street
don't they have a third one now
yeah they have right now killer ramen oh
you go you get the tsukemen right
yeah that's good
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you get it
yeah
okay and then i'll go to sometimes that
udon place what's that called
uh-huh
and you know what i got today guys and
this is you know your lucky boy
you know
in the books it has the best breakfast
burrito
who mine yeah lucky boy you just like
the way it's like tightly wrapped
there's a place that's better
i feel like you don't need vegetables
country
cottage
country cottage in burbank if you guys
live in la
go to country cottage get their
breakfast burrito
[ __ ] rivals lucky boy i went there
today dog you saw my lucky boy driving
in pasadena yeah it's not a drive-in
that's the best breakfast burrito one of
the best parts here in l.a that's not
one of my favorites and yes i do like
because you train right by there right
yeah it's just lucky boy driving like i
think the thing i don't like about it is
that the cheese is not melted
when you get the
yeah like sometimes it comes out cold
sometimes it doesn't oh i've never had
it not melted you have cross eyes
you like that you're one of those gooks
you're one of them gooks that [ __ ]
cross why don't you come train with us
who you and what if with the [ __ ]
mutant bart no they do muay thai and
that's subby mutant because you did
wrestling sub mutant that you hang out
with bark quan i bet you could i bet you
could tap bart out yeah you probably
could i bet you he's a yellow thumb
yellow joe rogan but yeah he is wrestled
and you were good
i was real good dude your brother always
talks about it yeah yeah my balance is
off the chain bruh i heard you have like
a solid five seconds at the beginning
yeah i do man but after that five
seconds it's a little yeah yeah it's a
little wrong i can do i can do a thing
where you're on top of me dude and i'll
roll you 100 i believe i will roll you
i'm i'm i'm frail as [ __ ] okay
so i am tough in that way and i'm strong
i have hrs everyone knows that you know
what hr is i think it means human
retouched right exactly
that's exactly what it means because you
get it you don't think you know
and you get it right i'm like a chimp
bro
you step you step at me dude i'll break
a cheekbone with my fingers what do you
think i all right i'm getting aggressive
right now dog with you i was agreeing
with you i asked you to train i love all
right but i was agreeing with you i want
you to come here i'm sorry i want you to
come on there's no residue what is
everyone
what is everyone so sensitive
as of late
okay
all i'm doing is speaking the truth my
friends and you guys are like oh i don't
want i don't care i don't know you know
this and that
right now is that we're taking a knee
here we go again we say something right
here by speaking our minds yes we're
taking a knee what we're doing with nfl
players are doing yes
we're we're exercising our right to
speak what's on our mind am i not right
white man come on jason all right yeah
and none of you guys are going to stop
me
is that your knee right there yeah well
he didn't yeah he took a knee but he
chose to put the knee up yeah it was
like yeah
you don't like uncomfortable things if i
bring it up no it's just i have another
thing i want to bring up
god i mean we're friends why can't we
talk yeah yeah he loves controversy it's
so dumb like when you and uh dr ken
fought in the green room
and i've talked about it
were you there because yeah it was like
cobb's first doctor ken spit in his face
but let me just say
we there was a little physical property
not only that what you do is this don't
they have the pretzel thing there that's
really good that's the thing this is
that every hot dog can be substituted
the bun
with a pretzel bun
ooh
i'll tell you why the pretzel bun
is the king of all buns
i'll tell you why please
you can guess if you guess if you can
okay i okay yeah
you go first why it's the king yeah um
because of the large pieces of salt just
as i was going to say the salt nope damn
that's why i like pretzels nope um it
doesn't fall apart or get soggy with the
mustard right exactly and the ketchup
it's it holds usually it's structurally
sound it's like
um
it's what the titanic should have been
made out of
yeah
yeah
um
it absorbs chili
it absorbs hot dog juices right
you know sometimes this is what i do i i
don't eat it right away you know i'll
take a couple of bites and i'll play
like you know russell or something on my
iphone i take a couple of sips of
lemonade yeah you know i'll go to
twitter i'll ponder the news right
and i'll go back into it right it's
always the same it's you can you trust
it
you trust the foundation
okay that's that's why it's good
any fast food place also that has
i don't give a [ __ ] and you can ar you
can argue this to the end of time
okay i don't give a [ __ ] and i'm
swearing okay
okay
fat fries beats skinny fries
any day of the week agreed a thousand
percent i hate skinny fries yeah like
like mcdonald's when people do straight
with this when they came up with the
string one
i don't want to eat potato pubes
it reminds me of earth like if the earth
had pubic hair that's what it would
taste like it'll look like potato peas
yeah i want thick ass
golden steak fries steak fries am i not
right i do like curly fries too
okay
chick-fil-a is a pretty good one babe
waffle fries okay too waffle fries are
great just no super skinnies yeah but i
just do love
i mean
but in fast food
and you have to eat it right away
but the best fries in fast food
and i'm going to start i'm going to
start more maybe
it's
mcdonald's
not even that thick because it doesn't
matter
i'm just saying mcdonald's fries
straight from
the fryer to your mouth
something happens in if you don't eat it
for 30 minutes
it turns to [ __ ] you know
but straight from the you know the fryer
to your mouth
so i think in hollywood it's almost
because i've done this before where i'll
meet an actor yeah and uh it was like i
met a couple actors like okay i was i
belonged i felt like okay i'm part of
this and i had to say something like hey
i i i just yeah i'm stupid because the
little kid in me comes out i'm realizing
i'm around big stars and i don't feel
like a big star or that or yeah anyway
and i say something and immediately they
look at me like oh you don't belong
right you don't fit
see i stopped talking because i know i'm
going to say something incriminating
about like if no like if i'm with
dicaprio right and i go what's up and
he's like how are you doing i'm going
yeah i'm all right and he's like so
how's the family i'll suck your dick
[Laughter]
you always suck your dick right now
are you like what what are you talking
about yeah i mean that's i'm so
desperate for like that approval
like oh this guy's weird no no no no no
no no no no i would really suck his dick
he chucked in
he would
i probably would he'd suck the capri
just out of fear and like
who's like
i'm sorry i'm sorry i don't like being
laughed at in my face like that you're
[ __ ] bullying me i'm sorry i didn't
beat a bully but here's the here's what
i'm looking for
bobby here's what i'll say though i
don't understand because it wasn't like
dicaprio said suck my dick suck my dick
and you're scared you went up to and go
i'll suck your dick no a fourth line in
how's the family i said pretty good
you know what i mean i'll suck your dick
or whatever you know what i mean it's
not the opening thing would you be
offended because no that's unnecessary
you know
hey hey
let's not talk about that right stop
stop you don't need to do that
you know the other thing that happened
to me today which was
i couldn't sleep that well i had to
shoot in the morning
and while i was leaving they go oh yeah
where are you going i go i'm done
you know you're not you're country
western dancing lion dancing i saw the
video do you guys want to see a video of
bobby line dancing there's a video of me
line dancing yeah i got it in my email
um they wait they sent it to me in case
you want to rehearse at home so you have
um footage of yourself and oliver line
dancing oh and um um uh travis yeah
travis yeah so three of you guys just
like right now
they they have it down i'm not so sure
about you was that difficult what did
they make you guys you're doing some
weird swing of the hips thing
unnecessary
lion dancing is very direct babe yeah
yeah you don't have to swing your hips
that widely yeah i'm going to do that
oh hey you haven't shot it yet no we
shoot thursday oh i'm excited i'm going
to yell at somebody from the show for
sending that
because that was the first time i ever
line danced yeah and so for me to be
judged based on the first time it's just
by me when those other guys have done it
before yeah right is unbelievably rude
crude and unprofessional
if i'm the first that's the first i
don't even know what it is that is true
he said contradictory [ __ ] it is i don't
know what line dancing is i never you
know the last time i saw it i think
in the accused when jody
foster gets raped on the pinball machine
they were line dancing
that's the only way i know it and in my
mind i'm like i don't like it because
there's rape involved yeah yeah oh
that's the stigma i never liked country
so it's like i don't know it
right have you line dance [ __ ] never
all right exactly does electric slide
count or no no it does not occur it does
not count that i've never no you got to
go to like they have something
we need
as a doctor uh we gotta help we gotta
fix it maybe maybe not
i mean his health man
you know no i'm serious yeah like you're
being real serious right not being
serious so you let me ask you something
what do you think is going on with me
your diet
is all meat you think i eat all meat no
veggies no
that's interesting it's potato vegetable
yes it is i eat that too
i'm just saying
you because you have so much money you
make a good living okay you could eat
korean everyone listening i do okay
thank you
you you could i know crystal leah i'll
tell you that you could afford eating
out
he could afford eating out all the time
right uh-huh i don't he doesn't go to
like soup plantation
does he
how is slow plantation like the healthy
spot no it's just not it's just veggies
cucumbers tomatoes
you know what i mean veggies
what did i eat yesterday meat
i did eat meatballs
walk us through like we just smoked it
yesterday
so yesterday i woke up and uh your
little filipino niece is staying with us
julianna
great oh yeah she's great and um so i
took her to warner brothers and i go
let's go to the smokehouses right next
to it and i had a prime rib so good
damn right you did yeah right but i had
fried zucchini chip
ripe fried zucchini he likes fried stuff
yeah but zucchini deep fried like that
is not healthy sweetie it did totally
just eliminate the outer part is
unhealthy but the inner part is healthy
no it's not you've already taken away
all like
deep frying it takes away all of the
good stuff oh
anyway then what else did i have then we
had the artichoke the grilled artichoke
that was good this is all at the same
place yeah at the same place
so i had a prime rib and then garlic
bread and then last night i had bossa
nova i had a fried chicken fried steak
beef right no it was a chicken like you
know fried chicken but deep fried deep
fried with batter fries that's my
concern is he's you guys are doing well
he's doing well that's the only thing
that could take him down is his health
that's why i don't go out to eat with
you guys anymore
dude we're not gonna eat after this
because i just can't we gotta we gotta
guess i gotta did they text back
i i have a episode i have to text but i
can't afford to
to eat as indulgently as him so i don't
go out to eat with him i just make my
own food at home because that shit's not
healthy could he do the intermittent
intermittent fasting you know what he
actually doesn't because i was doing
that every sunday i was doing it every
sunday i would not eat for 24 hours gil
that's his that's not his problem
because he actually won't eat for 16
hours but in those eight hours he eats
real pure garbage like taco bell i won't
eat 12 hours and i'll eat a fat burger
with fried egg and chili
yeah
then my body goes crazy and then
straight into like a strawberry
shortcake and then i go right to sleep
so that stuff is in my body when i'm
sleeping yeah he actually has a big meal
before sleep yeah
it's not good guys it's not good and um
you know it's very concerning
is he sleeping okay or no no today he
slept at like 10 o'clock in the morning
in the morning yeah
and i have a 10 o'clock in the call time
tomorrow morning too oh gosh i mean
yeah he's self-sabotaging i i i i how do
you jesus stay out of here i mean do you
what time do you go to sleep um like one
two two three that's better what are you
doing oh you're playing red dead
redemption which i want to talk about
okay
great segway
what a great you're a professional
i think everyone's also this really fat
guy in a canoe that hates me a lot why
on instagram why i don't know he's like
yeah it might be from whittier actually
he's a really really fat guy in a canoe
and he's always like his pictures he's
probably like 400 pounds he he might be
like filipino or asian but all his
pictures is just of him and his can like
fat body on a canoe that i'm surprised
hasn't sunk and like he just fishes it's
weird who hates me here's another thing
is that when i posted
this one right
the picture oh i was there you did that
in arizona right but then there was a
guy on here that commented i think it's
still there
that's disgusting why would you hire a
model that poor model you may have to
touch your
penis and then some guy said that's his
girlfriend he goes no it's not yeah he's
just a comedian yeah that you know what
right and then i was just i'm reading it
going what yeah
you know what it is
to the outside world or other single men
yeah they can't
co they can't agree with that or even
that can't enter in their mind that a
person that looks like you wait wait
wait wait stop
no
stop there
just stop there yeah i get what you're
saying yeah what the [ __ ] do you mean no
but when you said a person that looks
like you no just your vibe or just no no
no no no no no no no
it's not just my [ __ ] no no physical
presence it's my [ __ ] energy no it's
just your whole being
what so you think everything
to them they can't even believe there's
no way it's like an alternative why why
why i don't know yeah there's something
about you they can't accept you being
with a someone like that that's like a
lack of exposure it's like that guy you
told me in tempe bob went to the atm
right and
you're you guys are standing together
and then there's like a frat dude
look and then he looked at you guys
together and he couldn't believe it and
he was like [ __ ] pissed
to me it doesn't it's not i don't you
know first of all i don't look at kalyla
like she's like family now yeah i'm so
unfuckable no that's not what i mean no
but you know what i mean you'd rather
[ __ ] a pringles cam than me
[Laughter]
there it is
there it is but she's like i love her
right it starts to feel that way though
after you've been with someone for a
while it becomes so functional yeah yeah
you love each other a lot but it it does
start to feel like a sibling it's kind
of gross i wanna we gotta snap out of
that yes we gotta be lovers again cause
we had sex last week and it was weird
huh it wasn't weird you just it's